It's very rare that I'm home alone for dinner.
That's when I get to cook whatever I'm craving,
and today I was craving a steak pie with some mashed potatoes.
This is my version of a girl dinner.
I started by chopping up all of my vegetables,
taking all the Brussel sprouts off of the stock,
cut those up before moving on to slicing up my steak.
I browned off the steak and got a good sear on it before taking it out,
sauteing all of my vegetables for a couple minutes,
deglazing with some red wine
and homemade bone broth for putting my meat back in
some herbs, and letting that simmer for about four hours.
Moved on to making my rough puff crust,
let my heavy cream go until it separated from the way,
set that aside, and then made my dough by combining some flour,
salt, butter,
and ice cold water
and letting that sit in the fridge for about 20 minutes
while I got started on my mashed potatoes.
Put them in a large pot and let them boil on the stove
while I made some brown sage butter to go inside my mash.
Once my potatoes were done,
I rice them, combine them with the butter,
some heavy cream, season them with salt and pepper,
and after about 20 minutes,
I rolled out my pastry and kept folding the sides in,
kept repeating that process until I was satisfied with how it looked.
Popped that In the fridge for about 30 minutes.
At this point, my stew was done.
I put it in my pie dish, rolled out my pastry to go on top,
made sure it was big enough to fit over it perfectly.
Brush this with my egg wash,
and popped in the oven for about 20 minutes.
I also seasoned my Brussel sprouts and put them in the oven as well,
and after about 20 minutes it was perfectly golden brown and flaky.
Plated my pie with some mash and Brussel sprouts,
and before I knew it, half of it was gone.